des sols saturés par des jours et des
nuits de pluie font glisser des blocs
entiers de roches
les arbres sont déracinés ou encore
arrachés par la force des vents
se demandent comment il va pouvoir
dégager sa voiture
les crues emportent tout sur leur
passage
sous surveillance nous avons évacué les
populations et plus de 200 000 personnes
sont en courant
le métro de la ville est sous les flots
d'affaires de fortes pluies sont encore
attendues en Californie les routes se
sont transformées en rapides les crues
s'étendent à perte de vue
mais encore une fois dans un contexte de
réchauffement ça augmente la probabilité
d'avoir des systèmes plus intenses
parfois plus fréquents et ce qui est en
train d'arriver effectivement sur la
Californie et peut-être aussi
symptomatique de ce qui nous attend dans
le futur les quantités d'eau reçues
durant les derniers jours ont fait plus
de victimes que pendant les feux de
forêt qui ont ravagé la Californie les
deux dernières années ici Yasmine Khayat
Radio-Canada Montréal